mayo clinic did research for a few years
ago a few years ago they had
two seconds per image to look at that
and find like a three by three brighter
than ever pixel and tell you
hey you know you have cancer you have a
brain bleed that's crazy
[Music]
a lot wallach thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders how are
you today
i am very good i was looking forward to
this i am extremely excited to have you
here
all the way from new york and the ceo of
adoc i i just
love what you're doing i love the
industry you're doing
now that i'm as a young entrepreneur
thinking of what type of venture i want
to do later on
this is pretty much you know the the
story that i want to be able to tell
both to my employees to my family to my
friends to my girlfriend so
first of all thank you for making such a
positive impact on the world and i'm
gonna let you tell
more about adoc in a second but first
take me all the way back to your army
days you're in
tapiot what is that like
yeah so topiot uh for those that don't
know topiot is uh
considered one of the most uh elite
technology units in in uh real ministry
defense it's a very
um it's a very limited group of people
it's about
uh 30 to 40 folks every year um
and it's one it was one of the most
intense periods of my life
and i'm entrepreneur now so it tells
something
um as part of the program i served
um for a decade in the military of
defense
um so as most people listening to this
must might know uh us israel we all have
to serve in the military i've been
uh fortunate to sign up for a decade uh
when i was 18 uh to be uh to be able to
apply for this program
well you know i'm rounding up uh
of course but no but but i think that
one of the most inspiring things i think
that i'm observing through the show
first of all it's the non-linear career
pathways that people have
and i think that a lot of people
especially today you know i'm going at
stanford i'm seeing this rush
this urgency to go and conquer and you
know if you haven't
if you haven't done made a billion
dollars by the age of 24 then you're not
really relevant but
but the truth is that again in order to
build really meaningful things like what
you're doing with adoc you need
you need the mature experience and i'm
and i'm sure that those almost 10 years
as part of the idf really really served
you well
tell me a little bit about what you
actually did now you went to the
israeli air force and you started going
into artificial intelligence
that's also not the most common path for
somebody serving in the military
yeah so i've been as part of the program
i was very fortunate
the idea of the program is for for us to
innovate technology
in in the ministry of defense so uh i've
been put in the in the israeli warfare
air force when they didn't even know
that they want to do ai it was kind of
like
let's do some technology innovation
let's build up a team of top your grads
um and we it was actually kind of like
doing a startup
in in the military right uh we because
we started going around and speaking
with folks and seeing
you know what are the needs and ai
started kind of building up it was
the the beginning of kind of the
technological revolution with with
machine learning becoming much more
prominent
and so many use cases so many use cases
popped up
uh and it was so at those days i must
say i really enjoyed the service because
on the one hand
it was starting something for fresh but
it was very
very technologically advanced you know
working with academia
and taking all this cool stuff that were
on the shelf
but making them you know operational and
and making an impact so that was kind of
how the service looked and at the end it
grew up to be uh you know to be now it's
it's a whole department so i'm i'm very
fortunate to be there uh when when it
gets started
amazing and so you finished alpiot and
you
how do you even get into health tech
because what you're doing here
regardless of the fact that it's
leveraging deep technology and you're
going
really into artificial intelligence you
really are going into a very
difficult industry that has a huge
barrier to entry
right there's a huge upside and huge
impact to be made
but what leads you towards healthcare
yeah and it actually all ties to the to
the topio
roots uh so let's imagine me 18 years
old for a second
uh i was this pretty nerdy kid uh not a
lot of
let's say awareness into
what i want to do i just you know i i
knew i'm good with computers i
enjoyed that i enjoyed solving problems
um
and you know to be honest i was a bit i
was a bit uh let's say um
what is it cocky at the time but you
know i knew i was the smartest kid in
class right it's always like you learned
that way
and you go into topiot and basically the
first thing you learn is that you're
not you're finally not the smartest kid
in class you see there are people
much smarter than you so you learn
humility i think that that's a
very important lesson right and the
second thing i was kind of drilled with
is that we have talent and we need to
use it for a good purpose
uh and it's something that they kind of
drilled us to the core of our dna
and i might say that if you know when i
was 18 years old i didn't really think
about what i want to do
with my life with you know with my
capabilities
after finishing the army i knew like i
want to be in an area
where i make an impact where i feel the
impact and when i do the world some good
uh so that because was the overarching
thesis
when we started this yeah what we call
the the gimmel gamel so so you know that
you want to make a positive impact on
the world you know
that you want to leverage deep
technology and the convergence
to the field of radiology and using
artificial intelligence
how come so people you know sometimes
give lectures to kind of early
entrepreneurs they ask me you know
did you have the idea isn't that the
idea is all important with a startup
for me well i didn't have an idea what i
had is a team so i had my two
co-founders which were
awesome uh and just knew i want to do
healthcare that's the only thing i knew
and we kind of started going very deep
into that domain
so we had this i remember we kind of you
know we were sitting on some beers
it was late at night we had got this
white board with a ton of ideas you know
like 20 ideas
and we started we there is this
framework called the lean startup you
know the the one the uh
so we started vetting what are the risks
for any of these and we started
you know narrowing those downs uh we had
a doctor
uh a doctor dr guy and eve who joined us
at that that point in time
so we kind of started going through the
ideas together
and starting validating you know what
works and what not and i thought what
definitely wasn't the first i think it
was the fourth or the fifth in the list
and we kind of valued them very i
remember one story that that's a funny
one that
in the head so the first idea was
something in the er we knew there was a
big pain point people don't know what's
happening they are
so we thought how do we validate there
is a pain point uh so me and the doc we
we both went to
like i don't even remember where like in
er somewhere in israel
and we stood outside the emergency
department with like a survey
and asking everybody coming out like did
you find something wrong with the
experience
and and they actually they kicked this
out at some point apparently you can't
do that
uh you're not allowed to ask people
what's wrong with their service
but i just remember like so much uh it
was very fun that period like evaluating
all ideas asking
people uh so that was kind of the early
days until we've met
the idea of adoc where we spoke with
radiologists all across the world and
they kind of told us like guys we need
we need this yesterday
and that was the origin of we're doing
today so
so tell me a little bit more about the
pain point because that's always the
most interesting part
that also you know segues into the the
impact that if you were to solve it
properly which
which obviously a doc is the then then
you really find that match so
why do radiologists need that yesterday
is it a bottleneck
is it a problem of accuracy what is the
problem there
i think the easiest way to think about
it is
is looking at camera
cameras in phones okay so what happened
in in
iphone cameras right so two things
happen a
you have much more resolution right so
we have
much more much more data per image and
the second thing everybody's now doing
images right everybody's doing a selfie
and the same thing happened with
radiology so we had cheaper faster
scanners more more demands
you have like more and more images and
not only that the resolution of those
scanners
is 10x versus a decade ago so you have
this
massive overload of the of of data and
you just you need specialized people
radiologists are doing amazing job
really
they need to go through all of these
massive amounts of data mountains of
data they grew 10x in the last decade
and and gave you interpretation nowadays
mayo clinic did research for a few years
ago
a few years ago they had two seconds
per image to look at that and find like
a three by three
brighter than ever pixel and tell you
hey you know you have cancer you have a
brain bleed
that's crazy so that's the pain point we
have in radiology today
and i think that the craziest part is
that the the end of the sentence was
and we need that in order to diagnose
cancer right so you so you're taking
you know two crazy things that you need
you're both expecting to do something
that's pretty much inhumane even for the
most
the person with the most the
radiologists with the most expertise and
at the same time you're saying by the
way each this itch
each you know false negative that you're
saying here you you're misdiagnosing
somebody that doesn't have cancer that
has cancer right it's life exactly
right so what is the opportunity here
that you identify back in 2015
when you're saying we might be able to
leverage deep technology to actually
solve this
yeah so the opportunity in high level is
let's create insights from all this data
in an automated fashion right how do we
do that and the first pain point we try
to solve
is how do you reach the right patients
on time
right so let me give you an example
right you have a patient coming in into
the emergency department
let's say a female fell down a few
stairs nowadays
busy you have you know dozens if not
hundreds of patients waiting nobody
knows
who has a brain bleed who is not you
know many patients fell down the stairs
you're even doing the ct now that's not
the bottleneck today
they have enough scanners so you're
doing the ct but then what
then you're waiting
hours for radiologists to go into the
image and say oh my god this passion is
friendly
it could be hours for sure and for
elective care for example
you could have there are examples of
patients you know waiting
you know sometimes days unbelievable
that's unbelievable and so so what i
understand from that is that the
bottleneck here really
is this is the diagnosis and the
interpretation of the
of the image right exactly the question
is
how do you identify the right
patients you want to focus on first so
that's the first thing with data how do
you sift through the data
very efficiently to get to those that
need treatment right
and so then how do you actually go about
and work with the hospitals so first you
have to get the data
you have to get them to believe you on
some
level i'm guessing there's some overlap
in the meantime where
you have you're both competing and
working together with the radiologist
right in order to prove
some point or or you know shift consumer
behavior towards
the world that you're imagining
absolutely and it's not it's never
competing by the way
so we took the position and i think
that's the only position you can take
that it's not about a radiologist versus
a machine it's radiologist
there is a sentence i love it's not
about will ai replace radiologists
is will it radiologists with ai replace
radiologists without
right and i think that's where we come
in right
we want to make them like the bionic
super uh super
people that you know can go through
images very quickly why that's the
distinction why is that messaging it it
sounds to me like i have a feeling that
it is a critical messaging that
differentiation but why is it so
important
well there are two reasons uh a because
it's true
we can't so humans we're very good at
at solving comprehensive problems right
so going through a lot of data and
understanding you know what do we do
with this patient
and looking at rare diseases and
aggregating tons of types of emissions
humans are awesome in that
what ai is good at is asking a very
specific question
and answering that very accurately and
very quickly that's where ai comes in
so you need both you so that that's a
that's true
b you know obviously nobody wants to you
know
work with something that would replace
him so even if you're claiming it
which again i don't believe in but even
if you know even if
i don't think that's the right approach
like you can't come to someone and tell
them hey i'm going to replace you
let's work together in the meantime
until i do that i don't think it's a
possible
but b i don't think it's a good approach
in general and this is why
radiologists love the system they love
it because it makes them
uh be better so can you share with me a
little bit about
what's actually happening with adoc
today in 2021 you know in hindsight in
hindsight
how many you know i know you're working
with more than 400 hospitals but on
you know paint me a picture of the
impact thus far and and then i'd love to
hear from you where
where is this taking off like what is
the grand vision for adopt
so this last year even though kovid
was was pretty crazy i must say we've
quadrupled in in
in sales and and if i think about
company trajectory so
we got the first of the clearance only
two years ago so 2000 early 2018 right
first year is first penetration you're
getting it out there you're getting your
first you know
sites getting you know convincing in the
value showing some traction
um and just and radiologists were
so hungry for something that works
because they hear about ai all the time
and you see it in home you know we have
we all have alexa and we have like
movie recommendations and netflix right
so they're eager for ai
and finally they saw something divorced
and it kind of exploded this year i must
say and we're just
penetrating massive amount of hospitals
just because they're looking for actual
value and
you know once it started uh when they
started believing in it
then it started really uh catching up
right and so
tell me a little bit about this
partnering with hospitals
you're working with you know bodies that
aren't necessarily you know at the
cutting edge of the technology
and also like the explanations of what
you're doing it's not like saying okay
here's my
mobile application here i can easily
explain to you what each functionality
does you're basically saying
i know how to take the this image and i
know how to diagnose it
hopefully just as good as you know a
radiologist can
is there a problem with explaining it or
was it pretty straightforward for them
yeah so first of all just one quick
clarification we don't
do the full diagnosis we just do it for
the with the radiology so we for example
we prioritize
for him right but in terms of what
hospitals care about
it's it's actually a very good point as
a company we're really focused on
reducing the barriers for testing
because they're so skeptical
they constantly tell us you know is it
real is it not is it valuable is it not
so the whole company is built around you
know what don't take my word for it
just try it out that that's kind of the
concept of how we do sales
don't take my word for it and once you
do that
then i think that that's the key what we
found in hospital sales reduce the
barriers
and then create highly measurable value
so those are kind of the two steps
because
even if you get in the door it's hard to
really understand the value if you're
not measuring it so the measurement part
and understanding what is the impact you
do is also key so showing them for
example
that you reduce priority showing them
you a reduced length of stay
that waiting time in the ed those are
like critical things for them to see
to be really convinced and be able to
spend money on this right and how
important is the is
the mission part from now the company
perspective so now you as
sort of the one of the leaders in the
company when when you
look at the people that are working with
you how prominent is the mission and the
overall you know vision of
of the impact adoc is going to have how
big of a part is it
of your day-to-day journeys oh it's
massive
it's massive um and i'll tell you a
story that one of my employees told me
so we are working
unfortunately uh very very hard uh or
fortunately uh depending how you
look at so it's not like i i sometimes i
you know employees text me you know 2
a.m
uh we do you know we do maintain some
work-life balance but sometimes it's
necessary you know we're
surfing you know 24-hour critical
uh and and i had one of employees tell
me that
that whenever he has like a very tough
week you know with tough customer calls
uh he we get a lot of emails from
customers
um for example like about a patient that
a patient that's life was saved and like
a doctor telling us
sorry we got like two of those a week on
average
and like he tells me he has a kind of a
scrapbook
a virtual scrapbook with all of those
and kind of reviews them
uh over the weekend uh to kind of get
get him back energized
and i think it's you know even medical
device companies i don't think that
what i love about specifically what we
do is that you really feel
the immediate impact i think all
companies have a lot of
value don't get me wrong but i think
feeling that immediate impact is is
awesome and hearing like that story of
of patient that really got got different
care because of you i think it's it's
that that's what we're all about i think
that's incredible and i
when i look at what type of company i
want to build for myself or
or the type of types of companies that
i'm truly excited about i think that at
the end
it's about that impact it's about really
being able to
wake up every morning and and you don't
even have to explain yourself like why
you're doing what you're doing it's so
obvious and one of the things that i've
been
that i've been mentioning to a lot of my
friends one of them george berman from
innovation endeavors
i told him that you know i'm starting to
to think and
one of the things that i told myself is
as sort of a rule of thumb
no matter what company i build i it has
to be in a huge market and the second
one is second rule is
i have when i explain what the company
does within the second sentence i need
people to say i'm in
i love what you're doing and i think
that what you're representing here at
adoc
and and it's there's nothing to explain
i mean it's obvious it's a huge problem
it's a huge opportunity
both business-wise but it's making a
huge impact on people so thank you for
all the
for all the amazing work you're doing a
lot i have to in the last two minutes we
have i have to pick your brain
young entrepreneurs what would you tell
them what would you tell a young
entrepreneur just starting their
journey and you know granted you you've
done deep technology now you're
the ceo of the hugely hyper growth
company what what
key advice would you say a
get a mentor that's spooky
get a mentor and don't it just i have i
have a few
uh people that i admire and help me in
my journey
and they taught me so much especially
for starting entrepreneurs it's
you really have to have this backup this
guidance it really helps tremendously
um so that that's like number one tip i
would say
um and two
get the right co-founders
and it's it's easy to say
i can't find the right person so how
about i start with somebody that i have
potentially less fit no
they're so cute you're going to have so
many challenges
and the trust and when i say trust i
mean
it's a the safety to challenge each
other but also the trust that
that they're gonna allow you to grow
into your position we're all inadequate
in doing that
but you need to understand that if
you're doing something bad i'll just
tell you you're doing something bad it's
not a firing offense it's a learning
offense
if you know what i mean and that i think
is key so those are i would say my two
biggest tips get a mentor
for learning and get the right team i
just love that a lot thank you so much
for being so generous with your time i
really appreciate it
the last question and the most important
one that i have is three words you would
use to describe yourself
so i thought about in advance i'll do
i'll do this the first is kaizen
okay the second yes kaizen uh learning
mentality
second is effectiveness okay
we is optimism
and four is rule breaking
of course thank you so so much continue
making such a positive impact on the
world
i can't wait to see it grow from 400
hospitals to 40 000 hospitals
and and i just love what you're doing i
love the mission thank you for
everything and stay safe and stay
healthy
michael thank you so much